- So you want to go to Stanford. - Yes, I almost got a perfect score on my SATs
- You're a good student. But Sierra, what's your stat? - Excuse me? - Sierra Burgess is
Funny... A wonder... A true artist... A loser... Sierra Burgerss is a loser...
You are a magnificent beast.
Do you ever feel sometimes like you're the one teenager who don't obsess over looks?
Oh, sorry dude!
I wonder what life is like for rejects.
Move it, Frodo.
Veronica, Frodo is from Lord of the Rings.
You're thinking of Quasimodo The Hunchback of Notre Dom. - I meant looking at you makes me want to gouge my eyes out.
Who's that?
I met a guy. We texted.
- He definitely thinks that I'm someone else. - It's called catfishing and I'm pretty sure it's illegal.
- Oh my God. - Oh, like Veronica Veronica? - That's what I have to live up to?
- All the phone numbers in the world he texted mine. - You need to tell him the truth. - They're my words. He's falling for me.
- Are you more than just a hot jock? - Oh, you think I'm hot. - No, ha.
- Would you want to go on a date with me? - Oh, yeah.
I know you've been failing all your classes.
- So? - So I think we can help each other, but I do need a favor.
- Are you sure this is gonna work? - No. Oh my gosh.
Hey.
- So, how was your day? - Em, you know what? The audio's not synked to the video like at all.
- Maybe we should try again... another time?
- Yeah, sure.
- I can't believe it actually worked! - He fell for it!
- Do you think you could like me? - You are exactly my type.
Do you have any idea of what it's like to be a teenager girl and to look like this?
You know, the hardest part is allowing yourself to be vulnerable.
- You owe him the truth. - He's not ready.
I don't even know who you are anymore.
Wait... Your voice.
She's not that bad. She's actually kind of cool.
Growing up is terrifying. I don't know what I am.